i think you're right about there not
being uh dialogue
but there's certainly ways to
de-radicalize people who are this
entrenched
yeah unfortunately it just requires a
level of uh
manipulation and deception most people
don't have the skill to actually perform
or wouldn't want to due to
i don't know perhaps scruples there's
daryl davis no daryl davis was unable
so are you familiar with dale davis i
don't know daryl davis is
one of the coolest guys ever so he is a
jazz musician and i think is is it blues
or jazz i think it's blue
people think they're the same kind of
music maybe i'm crazy i don't know
i think he's a blues musician and he's
uh he's a a middle-aged black man
he said one day you know he i forgot i
don't know i don't want to ruin his
story but he saw a story about you know
the clan
and he thought how can these guys hate
me if they've never met me
and so he went to a clan rally and
like talked to these guys and actually
ended up hanging out
one of one of his best stories that uh
because i did a speaking event he was
the headliner
he said there was one guy who was in the
clan and
you know daryl's a musician he's he's
got friends he's got connections
turns out this clan guy was a big rock
and roll fan so he said
there's like this famous car from this
famous rock star he's like oh yeah i
know who's got it i can get you i
i can get you in it you can sit down and
this guy was like what
and then he was like he brings this clan
guy out to this museum or whatever to
see this famous you know hot rod or
whatever and
the clan guy hugs him and this guy like
that was it as soon as he realized you
know everything he was being taught
wasn't true
he said that there was uh what i i'm
gonna ask you
does daryl davis come from a faith
background i don't know
yeah i don't know that's a good question
he there was one guy he said that he
would hang out with him and the guy was
still very much in the clan until one
day he was at a rally
and they were saying things and he went
that doesn't describe daryl
and then he was like this doesn't make
sense but here's the best part
we put on a speaking event uh near my
house in
in the philadelphia area a few miles
from it and antifa
from way further out told the press we
won't allow them to come to our
neighborhood and i was like it's my
neighborhood i live here
threatened to burn the theater down so
the theater kicks us out
but we still had an event planned across
the street for the after party
and we refused like if we can go we're
gonna go and i was like i'll tell you
what
if we get banned from both venues i will
march down that street
yeah but the the the bar across the
street was like dude we're not
we're not backing down like this is this
is ridiculous like daryl's awesome
why would they try and get this guy
banned like well he's literally
converting
klansmen exactly but wait like you ready
for this
we have the we have the after party and
protesters showed up
local police had to seal off the street
and escort us in
we go inside and daryl's there and i
mean i'm like
you know or i met him at the event but i
was like good to see you glad you came
and
you know he asked me about the
protesters he goes out
to talk to the protesters as a black man
and you know what they called him
oh i don't i really i want to know but i
don't want to know tell me you know
you know four letter
and he made a post on facebook about it
explaining how he's been able to meet
with and talk with clan members and
white supremacists
and de-radicalize over 200 just by
trying to understand them and talk to
them
and that when he approached these people
they just started yelling and calling
him nazi and white supremacist and he
was shocked
dude this troubles me yeah like it's
like
most people have really not you know
walked the walk right this guy
de-radicalizing
200 klansmen yeah has probably done more
to fight actual white supremacy than
anyone in the country
um and yeah well you know you know why
they
uh and it wasn't just a bunch of random
morons being like
a lot of them were but some of them know
who he is yeah they knew he was
and they said you're friends with nazis
you're a nazi okay
association yep yeah so there were there
were i think a couple of the higher
profile activists who were organizing it
they were like we know you daryl we know
you hang out with nazis right i
think his method is good and that if you
try and interact with them on the street
it's very they're going to come out with
you with the mob
mentality but if you get them one-on-one
it's a little easier to do darren's
method
well his methodology the reason so uh
one so i i've seen the tactics and
techniques of this
are not just in the ideology in the
literature it's also in the activist
organizing which is
don't allow your activists to speak to
anyone
and i'm not exaggerating this is a a
tried and true
leftist tactic they use at almost all of
their programming techniques
for sure yeah during occupy wall street
they would actually tell everyone
they would say okay everyone we're gonna
you know do a march if anyone tries
talking to you
just chat them down don't let them speak
they're gonna lie
i was in san bernardino for up for a
protest it was a bunch of trump people
were like waving flags so antifa shows
up
i walk across the street and there was a
group of people wearing all black and
black block
and i was like i was like how's it going
like can you anybody want to tell me
just like what's going on i'm just
and then all of a sudden a woman goes
don't talk to him mike check
mike check mike and they all start
chanting mic check
they're actually barking at people now
have you seen these people oh yeah on
twitter literally
literally barking like dogs
it's like the goal is so strange they
have a thing
that's been around for a while it's
called mic check the people's mic are
you familiar with it
i'm not yeah so one person yells mic
check and then everyone else in the
crowd yells mic check back
okay they say the technique was
developed to make it so that
if you can't use amplification by having
everyone repeat the words everyone can
hear
it's actually a programming technique so
we talked about this
uh the other day with jack murphy
where i had coffee with jack so jack
mentioned that when they force you to
say something
it's rewiring your brain to try and get
you to say it right
it's part of the struggle sessions yeah
the people's mic is literally that dude
they did it at occupy wall street and
then so i went up to speak and i was
like
i just screamed at everyone in the crowd
as loud as i could
no mic check just overwrote well so the
idea is
if you say mic check and they say mic
check and you say all cops and they go
all cops are bad and they yell our bed
you're making them say it
over and over again all cops are bad and
so it's wiring their brain as they say
it and they see it and they believe it
i mean it's how you teach children it's
how you teach kindergartners the
alphabet and the states and
any kind of rote memorization that
structures grammar in their brains
structures reading literacy i mean
it it's all it's the same principle um
applied to unfortunately
so let's grow an adult let me let me ask
you man
every you you go on tucker you say all
this stuff donald trump
we're going to get it done what do you
think would happen if hillary clinton
was president
[Laughter]
well i certainly wouldn't have been dumb
enough to call on the president to
abolish a critical race theory but you'd
still have to there
there's no because you you want to make
it you don't want to make those kind of
asks unless you think there's
some chance of it happening otherwise
you're wasting your time
and and i don't think it's it's
appropriate you'd want to
the kind of um the posture at that time
when you're in the
minority is very different than when you
have a friendly administration and
you know and people you know kind of
upset at me about it and blah blah blah
trump it's like i didn't even vote for
trump in 2016.
i voted third party i wasn't i wasn't
into either either either major party
candidate and
but but i will say now and and kind of
in retrospect
maybe made the wrong decision because
frankly not only would hillary clinton
not have done this
at all um but none of the other people
in the republican primary in 2016 would
have done it either right
a president jeb bush would say oof
racial issues
get me out the door as far away from the
stuff as possible i'm going to
hide under the table and and and suck on
a pacifier i mean this is like it would
have been
it would have been a funny presidency it
would have been you know
yeah no but no more bush yeah no more
could you imagine like a pathetic and
weak inept bush trying to start wars
please go to war and that's the other
thing too and honestly from my own
perspective about the president it's
like
you know that was a fear of mine in the
2016 campaign it's donald trump as
reckless he's the chaos candidate they
had all these
beautiful linguistic instructions who
the 3 am phone call and all of these
kind of
ideas that were meant to so doubt in
your mind during the campaign and it it
worked and i think oh this guy i don't
know an open experience
you know fighting and i mean
you know you have a guy who you think
would be waging war in the middle east
if you would listen and he actually made
peace in the middle east it's
it's extraordinary first couple of years
are not so good uh yeah john bolton was
a mistake yes but things have been
have been improving a lot since he kind
of took the reins back yeah
so uh who do you think's gonna win i
don't know you know i was in the white
house today and uh meeting with some
folks and uh
you know it's it's tense anticipation
right because their jobs are at stake
i mean uh it's a it's a unique
employment environment where
if your guy loses the election everyone
loses their job
but the spirits were actually pretty
high people were excited people were
making plans for next year
um so i i don't think so and one person
told me something very interesting he
said
you know this would require a major kind
of
polling science error that we've never
had before
but i think so but during the brexit uh
process brexit was down and i may not
get this exactly right this is a
coming second hand but brexit was down
four points in the polling
and won by four points wow that's an
eight-point swing yeah um
from what from what they're telling me
so do you want you want donald trump to
win
i do yeah i've got some good news for
you when you said it i mean that's all
of it
you're like you want donald trump yeah
yeah stay with me mike
check donald trump so i got some good
news
uh i don't know what's gonna happen but
i can tell you it's not
so easy to say the polls are right uh in
an interview with politico
rob robert kahaly of i think pronouncing
it right
of trafalgar group said in 2016 first of
all they got the numbers right
it was trump 306 to hillary 232 and
they're saying
trump is going to win now um helmut
norpoth
is predicting trump a 91 percent chance
of winning with 362 electoral votes
based on his primary tracking model
which has been correct 25 out of 27
times more importantly
if the pollsters corrected their
mistakes from 2016
then we should have seen improvement in
the midterms we didn't
in florida they were off by four points
they they thought that desantis was
going to lose
yeah he didn't they were wrong the polls
were wrong again nobody brings that up
that was it i was reading today and i
said whoa
yeah that should have been a huge thing
and trafalgar group
brings up something really interesting
the conditions that made it so people
were scared to admit they'd vote for
trump
are a hundred times worse today than
they were in 2015 or 16.
in 2016 the worst thing is that if you
were voting for trump people would
would scowl at you yeah today they'll
come to your house
they'll throw a brick at you they'll mob
you at a restaurant they'll they'll uh
you see what happened in new york with
the jews for trump rally
yeah this wasn't antifa who did this
okay everybody says oh these these
anti-fun everything and yes there's
problems with antifa
regular progressive new yorkers started
throwing rocks and eggs at cars
and one person i think it was a woman
went up to one of the vehicles
and pepper sprayed children bro the
whole
the level of depravity from these people
so i tell you man
we're seeing a lot of people actually
come out wave their flags and march
around and say trump trump
i'll tell you this i've had i said i
just got uh some
some information from people i know back
home
in chicago like shockingly alerting me
to the fact that someone we know has
just voted straight republican
donald trump and down to the republican
for the first time in their lives and
they couldn't believe it
and i was like no yeah look i've got
i've got people i know in my life
where i'm like wow i can't believe it
they're voting republican
my friends and family are all chicago
deep blue chicago when i was like i
can't remember how old i was
my family told me we're going to the
polls today i said who do i vote for
just vote democrat for everyone
now i've got people hitting me up like
dude did you hear so and so they i swear
they came over and they're like dude
we're voting trump and everybody
and i'm like these stories are real yeah
because i saw a story on i think it was
the donald
the donald's on what down the
donald.when it's their own website
where someone was like you know our
neighbors came over and told us that
they for the first time were voting for
trump and republicans
and they had been democrats and they
were worried they said we were scared if
we told them
we were voting for trump they would be
like really mad at us and scowl at us
yeah and then they came in and said we
have to tell you like we're voting for
trump and then immediately the guy's
like i'm getting the maga hats
yeah so out of the hidden place in the
closet well i'll tell you
a story like that it shows you the fear
the individual has to admit to his own
neighbors he's going to vote for trump
and the text message i got i'll tell you
what i what what i've been told over and
over
over and over again by my friends back
in chicago is dude you can't tell
anybody dude i'll lose my job yeah
i'm not i'm you know what's really funny
whenever i tell these stories
i get all these leftists commenting on
my twitter being like tim's making up
stories again
you don't want to believe it they don't
want to believe that no they trump might
lose okay
but it is true that this stuff's
happening i got a friend i met during a
black lives matter
uh protest in ferguson
for years 2014 we met she's posting
black lives matter
orange man you know and then finally
when trump comes around she's tweeting
like i can't believe this what is wrong
with this country
now it's maga it's like dude i saw her
twitter feed and i was like this is
not so i sent her a dmm and i'm like we
met at a black lives matter rally
how are you posting like go donald trump
jr woohoo and maga2020
and she was like dude i started reading
i started actually watching the videos i
started actually reading what was going
on
and i was like that's it once the the
the leftists
desperately need to make sure that no
one reads news outside
of their echo chamber and that's why you
get the likes of brian stelter when he
went on he
he did this episode a year or so ago
where he's like don't go and watch fox
news
don't watch the spin only come to us or
you could i think it was jake tapper who
was like remember you can't read
wikileaks's emails
you can only only we're allowed to have
them that's what they've been
desperately trying to maintain
and then you had micah brzezinski and
msnbc say it's our job to tell people
what to think or whatever
it's like or control what people think
that's what they rely on
but if people do the research then all
of a sudden they're like
wait a minute thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you